[Musik]
putin führt krieg in der ukraine ein
vernichtungskrieg ein feldzug unter
falschen vorwänden doch nicht alle
russen machen mit es gibt widerstand in
putins diktatur
anschläge auf militäreinrichtungen
nächtliche sabotageakte
demonstrationen proteste im exil
russlands rebellische jugend macht nicht
mit will nicht in den krieg und geht
dafür sogar ins gefängnis die mutigen
begehren auf
[Musik]
vor einigen wochen erhält daniel einen
anruf aus der uni sein
einberufungsbescheid ist gekommen obwohl
er als student eigentlich vom wehrdienst
befreit ist in russland werden jedes
jahr im frühjahr und herbst junge männer
zum militärdienst einberufen daniel ist
gegen den krieg oder das was sie in
russland eine militärische
sonderoperation nennen
guten und routine ist ein mörder er ist
wahnsinnig er bringt aktivisten um er
bringt politische häftlinge um er bringt
gewöhnliche menschen um er bringt uns
alle um
muss es kann doch keinen krieg geben wir
haben das einundzwanzigste jahrhundert
und elon musk will bald zum mars fliegen
wie kann es sein dass in einer welt ein
mensch lebt er zum mars fliegt und ein
mann der unseren brüdern den krieg
erklärt
daniel ist politisch aktiv immer wieder
geht er auf demonstrationen gegen den
krieg wurde sechs mal verhaftet saß zehn
tage im knast er weiß worauf er sich
einlässt und will trotzdem mit uns reden
fast ein bisschen stolz zeigt er uns ein
foto aus der haft wo er mit vielen
oppositionellen und kritischen
journalisten die zelle teilte
ich saß hinter verschlossenen türen sind
der metalltür und mit einem vergitterten
fenster dies war wie in einem traum sie
es einsetzen
dank der haft habe ich menschen wie
sergei smirnov kennengelernt oder
dmitri muratow man kann man denn sonst
im gewöhnlichen leben dimitrij muratow
zu sehen bekommen
die russische regierung sei faschistisch
so daniel wie aus dem geschichtsbuch
leute schaut euch da die bilder an aus
nazi deutschland wo die menschen sich in
form eines hakenkreuzes aufgestellt
hatten und die arme zum hitlergruß
erhoben und ihr stellt euch da in form
eines z auf und ruft auch sieges parolen
da ist kein unterschied zumal für uns
für uns russen diese geschichte eine
sehr schmerzhafte ist
helsinki im frühjahr bis vor kurzem
kamen hier zweimal täglich schnellzüge
aus sankt petersburg an viele russen
flohen mit dem zug her seit ende märz
ist die zugverbindung eingestellt
michael hat es noch geschafft der junge
kunsthandwerker aus nischni novgorod
wohnt bei freunden und schlägt sich hier
so durch
es gibt viele gründe warum ich russland
verlassen habe
einmal aus moralischen gründen
ich möchte nicht mit einem land in
verbindung gebracht werden das als
aggressor auftritt und dessen regierung
diesen krieg begonnen hat
der zweite grund ist dass sich hier
ukraine helfen kann
flüchtlingen
ich weiß zwar nicht genau was ich tun
kann in russland konnte man sich den
protesten anschließen was ich früher
getan habe
ich war ungefähr zehn jahre in der
protestbewegung aktiv
[Musik]
michael ist mit 500 dollar in der tasche
gekommen seine wohnung in nizhny
novgorod wollte er noch nicht verkaufen
er ist 31 und damit eigentlich zu alt
für den wehrdienst doch er fürchtet eine
generalmobilmachung der russischen
regierung
wenn man die wehrpflicht in russland und
den krieg sieht würde ich die regierung
gar nichts glauben
sie liegt permanent
in jeder hinsicht in politischen oder in
wirtschaftlichen dingen
die lage in russland sei mit dem
orwellschen buch 1984 vergleichbar meint
michael totale überwachung durch den
staat repression und aggression
nahe zukunft riskiert russland so etwas
wie nordkorea zu werden
alles das was wir an demokratie gewonnen
hatten in den 90ern auch wenn das keine
einfache zeit war
das verlieren
wir gehen zurück nicht sehen oder 20
jahre sondern ins neunzehnte jahrhundert
ich sehr traurig für die menschen finden
[Musik]
hier in helsinki so meint michael kann
er vielleicht eine protestbewegung gegen
die russische regierung beleben und
ukrainischen flüchtlingen helfen das sei
er ihnen als russe schuldig
[Musik]
but to me in georgien eigentlich ein
urlaubsort für viele russen am schwarzen
meer
casinos große hotelanlagen manche nennen
es das las vegas des kaukasus
[Musik]
in den vergangenen wochen ist batumi für
viele russen zufluchtsort geworden es
sind immer mehr junge männer die in
russland nicht zur armee wollen das land
verlassen rund 30.000 russen sind
bereits nach georgien eingereist maxim
kommt aus einem moskauer vorort als der
krieg begann wusste er dass er in
russland nicht mehr bleiben will er hat
einen eigenen youtube kanal und wurde
schon mehrfach verhaftet wegen der
teilnahme an unerlaubten demonstrationen
gemeinsam mit seinem freund adele
organisierte er seine flucht maxime will
nicht in den krieg
ich bin kein soldat ich bin jemand der
nicht weiß wie es auf dem schlachtfeld
zu geht und was dort zu tun ist
und ich sehe keinerlei grund für eine
militärische aggression seitens der
russischen föderation
am allerwenigsten
möchte ich mit der waffe in der hand
gegen menschen vorgehen müssen
maxime war ein jahr lang beim wehrdienst
seitdem hat er keine hohe meinung von
der russischen armee
man muss sich klar machen dass die
russische regierung lügt ohne ende
ich habe meinen wehrdienst abgeleistet
und ein jahr gedient mir ist völlig klar
dass von der ebene der unteroffiziere
angefangen systematisch gelogen und
desinformation betrieben
soldaten haben keinerlei zugang zur
informationsquelle es gibt nur die
russische propaganda
adele ist mit maxxim ausgereist der
junge programmierer kann eigentlich
überall arbeiten will erstmal für ein
halbes jahr hier in batumi bleiben eine
rückkehr in ein russland unter putin ist
für ihn ausgeschlossen er arbeitet immer
noch für eine russische firma hat hier
noch kein bankkonto sein gehalt bekommt
der virtuell
ich arbeite für eine russische firma und
mein gehalt wird in dollar berechnet die
ich aber nur nach einer konvertierung in
crypto währung bekommen kann 4 prozent
gebühren durch die konvertierung aber
eine andere möglichkeit habe ich nicht
ich könnte mir auch mein geld in rudeln
überweisen lassen aber dann hätte ich
erhebliche verluste der rubel ist nicht
stabil
adele fühlt sich wohl am schwarzen meer
er liebt es am strand spazieren zu gehen
kann hier viel russisch sprechen und in
der stadt herrscht eine aufgeschlossene
atmosphäre
ich fühle mich wie zu hause als ob ich
russland nicht verlassen hätte alle sind
aufgeschlossen und gastfreundlich hier
als ich die wohnung gemietet habe hat
mich der wohnungs makler gleich zu sich
nach hause eingeladen mit seiner familie
bekannt gemacht und mich mit kaffee und
traditionellem kompott bewirtet
irgendwann villa del wieder zurück nach
russland hofft auf ein baldiges ende des
krieges
[Musik]
auch in georgiens hauptstadt tiflis
leben viele geflüchtete russen sie
brauchen für die einreise kein visum die
politische lage zwischen russland und
georgien ist seit jahren angespannt auch
weil die orgien richtung westen strebt
und seit einigen jahren mitglied der
nato werden will den überfall russlands
in georgien im jahr 2008 haben sie hier
nicht vergessen seit jahren stehen
russische truppen in georgien auf
verschiedenen militärbasen für lisa und
ihren mann mikael ist das erst mal ihr
neues zuhause ein zelt in einer
baufälligen wohnung in tiflis die beiden
jungen russen sind froh dass sie
überhaupt so schnell eine wohnung
gefunden haben auch wenn das haus
drumrum ziemlich marode ist
wir sind am 7 märz angekommen unser
bekannter hat uns in empfang genommen
wir haben uns gleich am anfang auf
wohnungssuche begeben
in russland waren mikael und lisa schon
vor beginn der sogenannten
sonderoperation ins visier der behörden
geraten weil sie kreml-kritiker navalny
unterstützen
ingenieur mikael hatte angst dass in
russland das kriegsrecht ausgerufen
und er zum militärdienst eingezogen
werden könnte
als putin den flächendeckenden krieg
begann wir begriffen dass wir nicht mehr
zögern dürfen dass ein neuer eiserner
vorhang droht und dass es bald keine
möglichkeit mehr geben wird zu einer
legalen ausreise wenn ich mich von der
einberufung zum militärdienst abgesetzt
hätte dann wäre das ein straftatbestand
gewesen dafür kann man eine
gefängnisstrafe von bis zu zwei jahren
bekommen
dass so viele russen ins land kommen
wird unter den georgiern auch politisch
diskutiert
die sanktionen die jetzt gegen russland
verhängt worden sind ich denke dass es
die auch unsererseits geben müsste und
dass man keine bürger russlands mir hier
ein lässt
wir sind ein gastfreundliches volk aber
wenn die russen schlechte ziele und
absichten haben können wir antworten
genau so schlecht
nicht alle wollen die visafreiheit
behalten auch der geschäftsmann und
parlamentarier amamou kakabadse fordert
ein neues einreiseverfahren casazza hat
eine sozialliberale partei gegründet und
sitzt seit zwei jahren im parlament
unsere partei hat eine initiative zur
einführung einer temporären visaregelung
angekündigt um diesen zustrom zu
kontrollieren wir sprechen hier nicht
von einem gewöhnlichen touristen der
putins regime flohen
katze fürchtet dass die falschen nämlich
regime treuen russen in georgien an
einfluss gewinnen und damit dem land
schaden
wir leiden nicht unter russen phobie wir
haben ein problem mit dem imperialismus
mit dem putin ismus der solche schrecken
mit sich bringt schon der uns schon
mehrmals begegnet ist das was jetzt in
der ukraine geschieht muss ein ende
haben es ist höchste zeit diese
imperialen ambitionen zu stoppen
lisa und mikael wollen erstmal in tiflis
bleiben es gibt immer etwas zu
reparieren in ihrer provisorischen
wohnung lisa hat einen job gefunden für
eine marketingfirma irgendwie geht es
jeden tag ein bisschen besser sagen sie
vor kurzem ist der ukraine andriy aus
milito paul zu ihnen gestoßen
beide männer haben einen job gefunden
bei einer baufirma
reparieren sanieren alte häuser und
wohnungen gemeinsam russen ukrainer
georgier belarussen es gebe überhaupt
keine probleme sagen sich seine
heimatstadt milito pohl sei komplett
umzingelt von russischen truppen so
erzählt andré und es gebe immer mehr
versuche der russen junge männer zur
kollaboration zu zwingen
ich bin weg gefahren weil dort so eine
praxis eingeführt wurde die daten von
männern zu erheben um sie zum
militärdienst zu zwingen
für die russische föderation
du hast nur die wahl weg zu fahren oder
mit dem feind zusammenzuarbeiten
michael und lisa gehen manchmal
gemeinsam auf friedensdemonstrationen im
zentrum von tiflis
[Musik]
ist ein punkt ist
fast täglich finden wir solche
zusammenkünfte statt solidarität zeigen
mit der ukraine auch als russen
es ist sehr wichtig die ukraine zu
unterstützen
gut dass hier das interesse daran nicht
nachlässt auch durch meetings und
plakate und andere aktionen
wer sich nicht an die geschichte
erinnert er ist verdammt sie zu
wiederholen
[Musik]
mörder missgeburt leider missgeburt
es gibt widerstand in russland gegen das
was die regierung eine sonder operation
nennt immer wieder nächtliche anschläge
gegen militäreinrichtungen
mit selbstgebauten molotowcocktails
die videos davon verbreiten sich schnell
in den sozialen netzwerken
aber es gibt auch subtileren widerstand
kleine botschaften in der stadt verteilt
schriften auf asphalt und mauern
[Musik]
friedls bänder in zweigen
nein zum krieg und tv liegt auf opel
scheinen
[Musik]
und nicht immer sind die behörden
schnell genug die schriften zu entfernen
ortstermin am moskauer galinski gericht
daniel war auf einer verbotenen
demonstration und wurde gleich
festgenommen 48 stunden
untersuchungshaft wir treffen ihn mit
freundin polina kurz vor der verhandlung
wahrscheinlich wird man eine strafe
verhängen um die 20 bis 30 tausend rubel
da dies nicht das erste mal ist wir
erwarten also nichts neues
daniel will nicht ausreisen will weiter
protestieren das system putin von innen
bekämpfen
wie können sich meine pläne ändern wenn
dies hier mein land ist ich hier meine
verwandten und freunde habe als ich
gestern auf freien fuß kam und die fotos
aus butter sah da habe ich begriffen
dass das zu viel ist dass man uns das
ganz bestimmt nicht verzeihen wird
nach ein paar stunden kommt daniels
urteil 10.000 rubel rund 100 euro strafe
noch einmal mit einem blauen auge davon
gekommen das nächste mal droht ihm
allerdings eine lange haft
der neunte mai der tag des sieges der
traditionelle russische feiertag für das
ende des zweiten weltkrieges wie jedes
jahr pompös
militärparaden waffen show klatsch
publikum doch dieses jahr ist alles
anders
die luftwaffe fehlt angeblich wegen
schlechten wetters aber strahlt der
himmel blau über den roten platz in
moskau und putin spricht das erste mal
über gefallene soldaten richtet sich an
die angehörigen familien der tod eines
jeden unserer soldaten und offiziere
dies ist schmerz für uns alle und ein
unersetzlicher verlust für die
verwandten um nächsten der staat die
regionen die unternehmen und
gesellschaftlichen organisationen werden
alles tun um solche familien mit
fürsorge zu umgeben um ihnen zu helfen
russlands krieg ist ein desaster
der militärische stolz des landes
offensichtlich nur bedingt einsatzfähig
ein durchmarsch in der ukraine gelingt
nicht der widerstand der ukrainischen
soldaten wohl nicht einkalkuliert und
die moral der russischen soldaten
scheint auch jeden tag schlechter zu
werden es gibt nachschub und
versorgungsprobleme diese bilder sollen
russische soldaten zeigen die einen
supermarkt plündern
und es gibt hohe verluste ein telegramm
kanal der ukrainischen armee gefallene
russische soldaten gefangen genommen
entstellt die echtheit lässt sich schwer
überprüfen der krieg der bilder der
kampf um die wahrheit tobt in den
sozialen netzwerken wie viele russische
soldaten gefallen sind ist in russland
staatsgeheimnis die letzte offizielle
zahl stammt vom 25 märz
1351 tote mittlerweile gehen schätzungen
der nato von rund 15.000 und die ukraine
gar von über 27.000 gefallenen oder
gefangen genommenen russischen soldaten
aus
sankt petersburg
zweitgrößte stadt in russland und die
heimatstadt wladimir putin bis anfang
märz wurde hier regelmäßig gegen den
krieg in der ukraine demonstriert die
polizei griff hart durch es gab viele
verhaftungen und doch gibt es immer noch
widerstand in der stadt gegen den
vernichtungskrieg in der ukraine in der
bar treffen sich journalisten und
künstler auch andré wurde schon mehrfach
auf demos verhaftet er ist journalist
und erzählt wie sich die stimmung im
land verändert hat
die gleichgültigkeit der mehrheit das
schweigen niemand vertieft sich in die
sache in persönlichen gesprächen sagen
die menschen die wahrheit alle haben
angst niemand durch glücklich viele sind
sehr wütend ich kenne keine genauen
statistiken aber etwa jeder fünfte russe
hatte verwandte in der ukraine das ist
grauenhaft
langsam schwindet die unterstützung für
den krieg so andree
selbst bei der winzigen minderheit die
die sonderoperation offen unterstützt
auch bei ihnen hat sich heute die
unzufriedenheit mit unserer regierung
etabliert es war wie eine
unausgesprochene vereinbarung in der
gesellschaft sie sagen wenn die
regierungsspitze in der ukraine spaß
haben will um einige ihrer
imperialistischen ziele zu erreichen nun
wir werden sie unterstützen aber bringt
uns auch die zweite grimm bringt sie uns
dann werden wir durchhalten
in der wut ba sind heute weniger leute
als sonst an einem samstag zum feiern
ist hier niemandem zumute barbesitzer
anton hat seit beginn des krieges
schwierigkeiten den betrieb am laufen zu
halten
lage ist angespannt dass das klar durch
die lieferausfälle wurde die arbeit in
der bar schwer und die preise schnellten
in die höhe als der rubel einbrach
heute spielt die band troja mama was so
viel heißt wie dein mütterchen was
ironisch gemeint ist
[Musik]
musik geht immer auch in zeiten der
sanktionen viele russen leiden unter den
gestiegenen lebensmittelpreisen oder
denken über ausreise nach
[Musik]
viele haben das land verlassen
vielleicht aufgrund von panik gleich
nach dem 24 februar sie waren sogar
gekommen um sich zu verabschieden
sozusagen zum letzten glas
am tag der parade des unsterblichen
regiments laufen tausende durch sankt
petersburg und gedenken der opfer des
zweiten weltkrieges eigentlich ein
marsch unabhängig von der großen
militärparade in moskau als eigene
unpolitische veranstaltung entstanden
doch mittlerweile hat auch hier die
polizei alles unter kontrolle
ich darf bei solchen öffentlichen
veranstaltungen nicht mehr auftauchen
weil die strafverfolgungsbehörden denken
könnten ich sei ein anstifter bei
solchen veranstaltungen bin ich generell
eine unerwünschte person heute haben
meine zukünftige frau und ich überlegt
ob wir zur parade gehen das ist ihr
wichtig aber dann dachte ich nein ich
will er demnächst heiraten
am tag der letzten anti kriegs
demonstration in sankt petersburg andrea
kuhn ist gerade angekommen hat noch
nichts geschrieben kein foto gemacht die
polizei läuft auf andre zu nimmt ihn
sofort fest er soll seine papiere zeigen
dann nehmen sie ihn mit der gefangenen
transport ist voll mit journalisten
der grund für die verhaftung ist wohl
dieses video dass andré einige zeit
zuvor gemacht hat die junge studentin
xenia wird auf einer friedensdemo von
der polizei an einer wand gestoßen sie
stürzt verliert das bewusstsein
helfen sie doch
andre ruf nach hilfe helfen sie doch
helfen sie ihr die polizei nimmt die
studentin bewusstlos mit andré weiss
nicht wie es ihr heute geht
der radiosender für den andré reportagen
geschrieben hat wurde gleich zu beginn
des krieges geschlossen zu kritisch für
das putin regime andré arbeitet trotzdem
weiter er hat einen eigenen telegramm
kanal und versucht so der überwachung zu
entkommen und putins propaganda etwas
entgegenzusetzen
wir haben nur die linie die die partei
vorgibt
wo sie existiert nur sie ist er laut
schauen sie sich die heutige parade in
sankt petersburg am newski prospekt
einer drei reihen absperrungen totale
überwachung und alles wird durchsucht
ich verstehe nicht dass man im ausland
glaubt dass alle russen damit
einverstanden sind
am ufer der newa ist andré mit kollegin
niqab redet mika hat versucht auf der
parade bilder zu drehen und interviews
zu machen unter widrigsten umständen ein
ständiges katz und maus spiel mit der
polizei
um nicht schon vorher festgenommen zu
werden verbrachte ich die nacht nicht zu
hause die wohnung wurde durchsucht ich
war nach der schon lange nicht mehr zu
hause ich treffe vorkehrungen
heute habe ich eine kapuze aufgesetzt
meine haare bedeckt weil die polizei
mich erkennt und mich manchmal mit den
worten wo ein bekanntes gesicht zum
gefangenen transport bringt
an diesem wochenende im petersburger
park sind viele unterwegs nika will im
park noch einige interviews machen mit
angehörigen von opfern aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg
eigentlich wollte sie nie journalistin
werden aber es sind historische zeiten
und die will sie kritisch begleiten an
der uni hat man ihr schon mit
exmatrikulation gedroht aber sie will
weiter berichten
angesprochen auf den krieg in der
ukraine antworten viele mit der
offiziellen rhetorik vielleicht aus
angst vor repressalien oder aus tiefer
überzeugung
wenn ich die möglichkeit hätte wäre ich
selber hingefahren ich habe viele
bekannte dort und halte kontakt ich
unterstütze sie voll und ganz
die propaganda vom besten funktioniert
schlechte propaganda von der anderen
seite diejenigen die ihr zuhören geraten
in panik und verlassen russland wenn wir
über perspektiven sprechen die gibt es
hier auch ausländische unternehmen gehen
weg russische werden erscheinen es
kommen neue möglichkeiten auf
einheimische unternehmen und wie importe
werden ersetzt
jetzt gibt es hier eine menge spannungen
ich liebe russland sehe ich schwärme
dafür ich liebe die kultur und die
menschen aber ich möchte ruhe haben
damit nicht das passiert dass sich alle
böse angucken und sagen du bist russe
spare auch beim essen weniger leckeres
keine schokolade weil sie sehr teuer ist
ich kaufe so einfach wie möglich
buchweizen reis hühnchen und versuche
etwas daraus zu machen
wieder ein gerichtstermin in moskau
daniel und seine freunde warten auf
dimitri der student hat den telegramm
kanal die uni protestiert gegründet ihm
droht ein strafverfahren wegen aufruf zu
protesten
hier ist ein polizist wir gehen jetzt
zurück zum polizeirevier seltsame
situation das gericht lehnt die aufnahme
eines verfahrens ab ich werde angeklagt
wegen wiederholter verletzung der
durchführung der öffentlichen kundgebung
sie haben irgendwelche beiträge in
anonymen telegramm kanälen gefunden die
zur teilnahme an der kundgebung aufrufen
und sie beschuldigen mich der autor
dieser beiträge zu sein die kundgebung
war vor einem monat aber aus irgendeinem
grund entscheiden sie sich gerade jetzt
diesen fall in betracht zu ziehen
seit unserem letzten treffen hat sich
nichts geändert aber was jetzt mit
meinem guten freund dimitri passiert
lässt mich natürlich denken dass es
höchste zeit ist russland zu verlassen
aber im moment bestehe ich weiterhin
darauf dass wir bleiben und irgendwie
für eine schöne zukunft kämpfen müssen
wir versuchen etwas mit dem anwalt zu
machen wenn wir uns der richter
mitteilte wollen sie ihn schon jetzt ein
strafverfahren anhängig und das wissen
sie heißt bis zu fünf jahre gefängnis
und das ist ernst wir werden versuchen
dass es bei der verwarnung bleibt
daniel und seine freunde begleiten
dimitri zum polizeirevier wo er in
untersuchungshaft gehen soll für die
nächsten 25 tage er wird weiter
protestieren wie viele seiner
kommilitonen
dimitri will seine diplomarbeit in der
haft schreiben will sich nicht
unterkriegen lassen
stolz mutig mit ungebrochenem willen
russlands rebellische jugend wehrt sich
gegen den krieg gegen die diktatur im
eigenen land auch aus dem gefängnis
[Musik]